Hello world,
it's arrived and the Internet of things.
It's definitely a buzz word these days,
but it's a real thing and I'll demonstrate
how to use reinforcement learning to
optimize electricity consumption amongst
multiple devices in a smart home.
Marc Andreessen's quote,
that software is eating the
world still rings true today.
More and more devices are
coming prepackaged with
Internet access that would
normally be, that includes smart sole
shakers, smart rectal thermometers,
smart mugs, smart
chairs. The list goes on,
and because these devices have a
connection to the worldwide web,
they can communicate with the outside
world and each other sharing information
and even learning from one another.
This internet of physical things is
becoming increasingly common across the
globe, whether it's a smart home,
a fleet of self driving cars,
or a pipeline of assets as they
are shipped across the globe.
Having a web of interconnected physical
devices has a huge range of use cases in
our modern world for
businesses and consumers.
But a major concern regarding
these devices is the amount
of energy they'll need
to consume. Silicon chips need
electricity, and the more devices we have,
the higher our energy costs will be.
It turns out that we can use reinforcement
learning to create a system that will
minimize our electricity
costs substantially.
This can apply to a whole
range of industries.
We're an interconnected system of devices,
is required to perform a task,
agriculture, manufacturing, and even a
personal home, which will be our demo.
Google recently used RL to reduce the
amount of energy they used in their data
center by up to 40% just
like a laptop generates heat.
They're massive racks of
servers generate a lot of heat,
but too much heat can damage the servers.
So a cooling system is necessary to
help maintain a certain temperature and
because it's such a dynamic environment,
a learning system is required
to set that temperature.
A whole host of unforeseen scenarios
like changes in weather and power outages
can occur. Also, humans interact with
the equipment in unexpected ways,
regularly probably doing
the floss stance on them.
And each data center has a unique
architecture and environment,
so their system needed to be able to
adapt to multiple unique environments.
Last week we introduced the fundamental
way of framing the reinforcement
learning problem where an
agent is interacting with
an environment to maximize
our reward.
The mark comp decision process.
The goal of an agent is to learn a
policy so it knows given a state the best
action to take in order to maximize
or reward and in a complete Mark Cobb
decision process or all of the
environment variables are known,
we can use dynamic programming
to learn an optimal policy.
But what if we don't know all the
environment variables beforehand?
Give up? No. Then it'd be
considered not to model based RL,
but model free RL in model free RL.
The first variable we miss
is a transition model,
so we won't know what's going to happen
after each action we take beforehand.
This tells us the probabilities
associated with various state changes.
The second thing we miss
is the reward function,
which gives the agent the
reward associated with a
particular state beforehand.
So when we don't know either
of these mark Cobian variables,
dynamic programming won't work.
We need to instead use a different
type of method called Monte Carlo.
Monte Carlo methods are a broad class of
algorithms that rely on repeated random
sampling to obtain numerical results.
The keyword here is random Monte Carlo
methods make use of randomness to solve
problems, which turns out to be very
useful in mathematics and physics.
Stanislaw ou alum invented it in the late
1940s while working on a nuclear bomb
as part of the Manhattan project.
Then John von Neumann decided he liked
it and programmed a machine to do those
same calculations.
They decided to name the codebase.
Monte Carlo has every super secret
project should be named UHMS.
Uncle happened to be losing lots of money
in the Monte Carlo Casino in Monaco,
so that's why uncles,
in fact,
deep minds alpha go use what's called a
Monte Carlo tree search to help it play
against the reigning go champion resulting
in move 37 more on that at the end of
the course.
Monte Carlo techniques have several
advantages over dynamic programming.
First,
they allow for learning optimal behavior
directly from interaction with the
environment without needing the
transition or reward function defined
beforehand.
Second,
it's easy and computationally
efficient to focus MC methods.
On a small subset of the total states and
third MC can be used with simulations.
So let's say we have a home that
consists of a bunch of internet of things
devices. We've got a smart TV,
a smart fridge, a smart dog,
and a smart giant server in our room.
All of this equipment requires
a lot of electricity to run,
but it also requires cooling or else
my room would get too hot so I have a
cooling system.
Now let's say that we have access
to our electricity usage logs,
thanks to partnering with a data friendly
provider and our smart thermostat can
set the temperature accordingly.
Depending on the type of system we built,
we can imagine electricity
flowing into all of these devices.
Creating a closed loop system and this
constant stream of electricity data can
definitely be utilized. It's giving us
the electricity, price, cooling demand,
and electricity consumption as variables.
Using this,
we can construct our mark
hub decision process.
The goal of our system is to
minimize our electricity bills,
more money for GPU.
Still now our agent will perform
an action in this environment.
That action will be to either increase
or decrease the temperature by one degree
Celsius. My fellow Americans, most of
this audience uses the metric system.
The state then that our agents can be
in will be a measure of both how much
cooling demand there is as well
as the price of electricity.
The reward can tell us whether we are
saving money or not by switching states by
calculating the total electricity
consumption multiplied by the price of
electricity and depending on if that's
greater or less than what existed the
time step before we know whether or not
that is a positive or negative reward.
There exists an optimal policy here such
that if we were to give it a state in
this case that would be the cooling
demand and the electricity price.
It would know exactly what temperature
the thermostat should be set at such that
we are optimally saving money on
electricity by cooling our room as much as
necessary when necessary.
Our adaptive real time reward based
system needs to learn this optimal policy
and since we don't know the reward
function or the transition function
beforehand,
we have to compute our rewards and
transitions as they happen in real time.
We'll want to use a model free technique
like Monte Carlo to learn the optimal
policy.
The basic idea is to calculate the value
function of each state backwards with
the reward received.
After the end of the episode
there has to be an ended,
then the task has to be considered an
episodic task for us to use Monte Carlo.
In our case,
we can say that an episode last a full
eight hours while I'm away at my office
working diligently,
if we move from the initial state to the
terminal state according to the given
policy,
will receive a reward at each time step.
We'll remember all those rewards and
when we get to the terminal state,
we'll look back and calculate the value
function of each state in the case that
there are multiple episodes, then Monte
Carlo just averages all of the returns.
We know that the return is a
sum of the discounted or reward.
In the context of Monte Carlo,
though we switch it up to obtain the
state value function we take instead the
expectation of the returns not the sun.
We can define a state s to be a discrete
random variable which can assume all
the variable stats with
a certain probability.
Every time our agent reaches a state,
it's like we are picking a value for
the random variable s for each state of
each episode. We can calculate
the return and store it in a list.
Repeating this process.
A lot is guaranteed to converge on the
true state value function in Monte Carlo
Rl. We are estimating the value function
for each state ace on the return of each
episode and the more episodes
we take into account,
the more accurate our estimation will be.
Notice though that a
possible problem could occur.
What if we visit the same state
twice in a single episode? Well,
there are actually two types of
Monte Carlo policy evaluation.
First visit and every visit we'll
focus on first visit in this video.
First visit only recognizes
the first visited state.
Every second visit does not count the
return for that state visit and the return
is calculated separately for each visit.
Monte Carlo includes randomness
because when it updates every episode,
depending on where it originated from,
it's a different result depending on
which action we take in the same state
because it contains these random elements.
Monte-Carlo has a high variance.
When we graph a simulation of
our agents solving our problem,
we'll see that eventually the policy will
converge and then our system will know
exactly what temperature to set our
room ace on the electricity related
variables.
There are different kinds of Monte Carlo
techniques that can do all sorts of
cool things,
but we'll talk about those later on.
Three points to remember from this video.
In model three reinforcement
learning as opposed to model based,
we don't know the reward function and
the transition function beforehand,
we have to learn them through experience.
A model free learning technique called
Monte Carlo uses repeated random sampling
to obtain numerical results.
And in first visit, Monte Carlo,
the state value function is defined
as the average of the returns.
Following the agents first visit
to s and a set of episodes,
please subscribe for more
programming videos. And for now,
I'm going to try a new sample.
So thanks for watching.